sometimes you get like 10K for like a
six second Vine I was just doing
stand-up one night David was in the
audience just knew that there was uh
something there for sure he just goes
Jay
I got it
bury you in the backyard
[Laughter]
but first before we go into that we
gotta thank today's sponsor Creative
Juice look if you're a Creator you've
probably realized unfortunately that
creating content is only a very small
part of your business like there's so
many other things that just take up your
time that aren't really that fun and
managing finances taxes and expenses can
be incredibly overwhelming especially if
you're not sure which transactions are
business or personally is Right Ranch
and that's why Creative Juice is a
perfect solution for creators just like
you not only do they offer a business
banking account with a debit card and
rewards but they also offer automated
and personalized tax tools specifically
for creators if you don't know where to
begin with taxes begin with juice now
you could categorize your expenses in
real time to simplify write-offs for all
expense types like your daily Starbucks
juice also offers a 1099 IRS compliant
tool that allows you to pay your
contractors efficiently I do my favorite
part is that you get access to
creator-minded CPAs that'll help do your
taxes for you let's use automate your
business simplify your taxes and provide
the funding you need to focus on what
you enjoy the most which is creating so
sign up for a free Creative Juice
business banking account with the link
down below or visit getjuice.com and the
link is down below in the description
Jack now let's get back to the video
what did you get from Starbucks what is
that I got a Triple Espresso with almond
milk every morning every morning yeah
yeah I don't like cold brew it gives me
a headache really yeah I don't like cold
brew oh why is that I think it's
something about the way that it the
I don't know how you know the way it's
uh pulled out yeah in the cold it [__]
me up how do you guys feel about energy
drinks not a fan I feel like they got to
be so unhealthy they make me kind of
sick yeah that's what it is Red Bulls I
could kind of see but I don't like the
taste it has a very like uh you know
citricky taste yeah but then you get
into like the monster energies and that
sort of stuff I don't like Rockstar
where you the candy is like Twisted off
the top yeah I tell you what's delicious
is that that Prime energy drink yeah
it's delicious but it it like sends you
off I've had it before I think it's
actually it's really sweet I'm surprised
how they got it so sweet only being like
20 calories yeah it's aspartame isn't it
I think so yeah
so it's the artificial sweetener that
has no calories it tastes really sweet
though right the downside with that
apparently is that if you could control
it it's really good but it activates
something and I could be totally wrong
in this it activates something that it's
like a sweet gland in your brain yeah
makes you more likely to want sweet
Foods after that yeah yeah so like
that's the danger word you could just
like contain it it might be okay but
like you'll be craving other sweet
things afterwards and that's kind of
weird yeah I could see that where the
danger comes in that happens with Diet
Coke with me yeah oh Diet Coke is
addicting man yes it's dangerous so good
it's so good I'm curious though has your
caffeine coffee intake and your diet
changed recently because I saw that you
you went through this like incredible
transformation with Fitness oh yeah and
you're like really jacked now like the
six-pack and yeah I'm trying do you
still have a six-pack uh sort of really
yeah it comes and goes depends on like
to have a six-pack you have to um you
have to just really limit your calories
so I have like a two and a four pack
but then the lower is it'll always tough
it's tough yeah you have to really
really
um
watch what you eat and so that that's
that's what I did I was just really
heavy and I was just like and I just
felt awful all the time and uh and then
I just got to be I'm gonna be 50 in May
and I just got to be like okay I I gotta
really just try to clean up my life and
so I just started to
um yeah I just like slowly got down to
like a really specific diet and just
eating the same thing every day uh or
the same types of foods every day and uh
and yeah and I'm just much happier that
way cool you know it's almost like a
like an alcoholic who's like yeah like I
would love to have a drink but you know
my life is way better
without alcohol you know so I'm just I'm
just that way with food so I'll just
I'll go off like I will I will eat in
the middle of the night I'll sleep eat
um sleep eating sleep eating is like
when you just wake up in the middle of
the night and like like start eating
really yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah wake you
up though does it wake me up yeah I mean
I'm up I remember it okay but I'm still
doing it I'm just like it's so is there
a reason behind why you want food at
that time yeah I just have like an
addiction of to food like since I was a
child like just uh
you just like food is so comforting to
me that's that's why so I think that's
why and uh you know it it sucks because
like I was fat as a kid and uh yeah you
just gotta like I just keep working on
it
it's a struggle it's every day what was
the big change for you because it was a
pretty abrupt shift it seems like my
perspective well I'll tell you what a
really big thing was was my friend Ilya
yeah he um he started this like Fitness
company and he started to get everybody
in shape and uh and all those guys that
I'm friends with they're just like a lot
younger than me and
um there was just probably just
something in me that was just like oh
you know I I can do it too you know yeah
so when you're like around that and um
you know it makes it fun and it feels
good you get like a dorphin rush and
then so it just became a thing like
every morning
um
just going out with Todd and Hiking
doing Runyon every morning and you just
become addicted to it you become
addicted to the that high and uh and
then yeah you just keep working at it
and the more you the more you go into
like a a workout Journey
um you can see that you can like oh wow
I'm going deeper and deeper and deeper
and deeper and deeper into it and it
just it makes you want to just like keep
going and uh and it just feels it feels
so good I just never been I've never
been happier that's really cool I really
I really haven't what other changes have
you noticed because of your current
Fitness oh everything everything sleep
better like I have sleep apnea so like
when like I have like a lot of like fat
around like my neck and stuff like I
don't breathe at night so I I sleep
better I uh I can walk up the stairs
better
um your clothes fit uh you have more
confidence like you know like if you're
just even out at a party and you're just
like you you know you feel like I don't
belong here you know
um you know now you're like okay I I'm
I'm the best version of me that I can be
and um and that that that allows you to
like not beat yourself up you know so
because normally I can I can I can like
really spiral down and be like Oh I'm
[__] and I'm not uh I'm not funny and
I'm not this and I'm not that and I'm
not as especially like being around
um
you know like around what we do there's
like so many fabulous people that you
meet all the time you know like
uh and so you feel like oh I'm not as
funny as them or I'm not as talented as
them so at least I know that like if I'm
keeping myself in shape I'm the best
version physically and that's one less
thing that I that I won't beat myself up
about I'm I'm good I even coming here
today like I said to my fiance I was
like oh man I can't work out you know
because I'm going to do the podcast and
she was like you look great she's like
don't worry about it and I was like okay
yeah you're right it's so funny I would
be on your side and be like no you gotta
work out yeah honestly I'd be like I'd
find a way to work out yeah man see I
would be the type to cancel and just be
like no I want like I gotta hit the gym
like that's a non-negotiable thing yeah
yeah it's you just and that that's
another part of it too is like you
you want to go every day and you need
that level of commitment to
to feel good going every day how do you
prevent yourself from falling off of
that because I know for me if I don't
keep such a disciplined uh like uh uh
like output
um or consistency with it if I I just
fall off pretty easily so I got to be
like 100 or zero yeah 100 you just have
to be 100 I I there's I guess there's
just like a feeling in my brain now
which is like if I don't go do it
then I'm I'm like disregarding all the
work I've done yeah so it's like okay
I'm here today I'm 172 pounds and uh but
if I don't go to the gym today then I'm
like I'm going backwards so I don't want
to go backwards are you going to go
today uh after this oh it's kind of
rainy
I love how if you correct your Fitness
every other facet of your life is
basically improved what I've noticed
with my personal life it's like I hear
so many people saying you gotta grind if
you want to become successful and you
should go down this Avenue if you want
to do this and this and this but if
they're not focusing on their their
health first I think it makes it so much
harder to become motivated to be
successful in other facets of life if
you solve this root issue of your
personal fitness everything else good in
life will follow suit I think yeah yeah
I think so that's what I've been trying
to do is just trying to keep every area
of my uh just to have balance and keep
every area in check all my relationships
uh my working out my work my kids
um and uh yeah you have to you have to
tend to everything you have to like it's
like a garden you know it's like okay
I'm doing this and you're feeding this
and you're feeding this and taking care
of this and um yeah it's I don't know
it's definitely I definitely like this
age the best this is my best age good
for sure yeah it's it's the most fun
when I was younger
um I would always be like concerned like
Huawei where I'd be somewhere and I'd be
like oh I should be somewhere else or I
should be doing something else but now I
I I've learned to just be like uh oh
really really good this is what we're
doing right now enjoy this and
and uh and that's it you know do you
think you you felt more pressure when
you were younger that you had to perform
at like the the best or you had to be
busy or what changed yeah when you're
younger you when you're younger you just
don't you just don't know you're just
like
I wasn't I I we didn't have the I I I
didn't have like the internet back then
no so there was uh when you were as far
as a career it was like more gatekeepery
kind of stuff so you would go to like
ABC or fox or and be like here here's my
sitcom and you would pitch it and then
they would say okay go write it and then
you would like go write it and then they
would be like we're not gonna pick it up
and so it was just like very you just
felt stuck all the time and so then when
the internet came around
and things weren't going great for me
and like TV and movies
I was just like okay I'm gonna go do
this and it was like really freeing and
then I was able to to just like you know
find some success and really enjoy what
I did and enjoy life more but when
you're when you're you know when you're
younger I just feel like
I mean I see it now with a lot of my
younger friends like they seem
they seem lost in a way even though they
have a lot but there's certain things
that I'm like I wish I could just tell
them but you can't really tell anybody
you just kind of have they just have to
go through yeah but you know what hold
on to that for a second because I found
it very interesting that in our last
podcast episode 93 of our viewers were a
male and 87 were over the age 25 which
is exactly why we're excited to thank
our sponsor Roman Roman offers
science-backed treatments that are
proven to either slow or completely stop
hair loss or in some cases even regrow
it let's be real losing your hair could
really take a toll on your confidence
and trust me I know a thing or two about
low confidence but up to 70 of men who
used minoxidil treatment reported
increased hair growth after just four
months Roman can help you get the
treatment you need to fight back against
balding and the best part is that you
can do it completely from your phone
without waiting in line at the pharmacy
or driving to your doctor's office Roman
offers prescription strength oral
treatments as well as topical options so
you can get the medication that's right
for you plus Roman offers fast free
shipping in discrete packaging so you
can get started with without anyone
knowing don't let hair loss take away
your confidence get more confidence from
the top down with Roman visit the link
Down Below in the description today to
get your first treatment for free or you
guys can go to road.co iced coffee hour
to get started completely free thank you
so much Roman and let's get back to the
podcast let's talk about your story from
being a kid growing up because you have
a really interesting story and so many
different pivots in your career to lead
you that led you to where you are right
now can you talk about like growing up
and then all the events that occurred to
bring you here I I grew up in Boston in
a suburb Mom and Dad great mom and dad
parents got divorced uh got a sister
was like overweight as a kid but you
know and I I was I had friends and stuff
which was cool
um I grew up with a lot of Meat Heads a
lot of like Boston people that like
fought and were tough that I was never
tough you wouldn't fight no no no no no
no never never why not why not yeah if
everyone else is fighting like what's
their what if anyone else jumps off a
cliff yeah to like how I thought I was
like this is so silly like what do you
guys what are you guys fighting over you
know it would be like keg parties and
like big brawls and I'd be like standing
there you should be watching uh yeah I
was pretty clear with them I'm like I'm
they were my friends but I'm like I I'm
not gonna fight like this is so dumb
and uh
you know I don't know it it just like it
that that whole mentality of
you know being a guy and like fighting
and stuff it just never my father always
wanted me to play football I just didn't
want to I was like I'm not gonna go out
there and get hit are you crazy what was
it in you that made you that way like
all right
it's a fist you could be not about
fighting you know you don't want to harm
people like I mean there are you know
good sides to the Token uh
it just felt so it just felt so dumb I
mean I guess in a way like I was a bit
of a I was I was I felt like I was above
it
sure
fighting I'm being honest but I probably
felt like I was a little snobby like
yeah like honestly like is this what
we're doing guys because I was into like
I was into like comedy and stuff I was
into like Saturday Night Live and I was
into like comic books and like
um
uh just any kind of comedy movie and
stuff like that and then but but no one
I had a lot of Comedy uh albums and I
would show my friends I'd be like oh my
God this is Eddie Murphy Raw you know
and they'd be like yeah it's funny yeah
I guess so it's just there was just kind
of like uh and that was the great thing
about moving to LA and stuff it's like
you met people that like
you were you were like if you were like
a comedy nerd here you were you were
like celebrated like there was like so
many people that were like into that
kind of thing or when I moved to LA
people would be like you know uh just
the idea of like going to see a stand-up
comedian live was like
oh wow like that's awesome like you guys
like to do that like that's great so
that was that was really cool to find
that I mean my favorite thing that I've
done in the last couple years other than
be with my kids is just go see we saw
Dave Chappelle at the Hollywood Bowl
that's cool like it was just
you know when you go to a concert and
you're like it's good yeah but then
you're kind of in and out you're like I
don't really like this song like oh I
like this song the songs yeah yeah Dave
Chappelle is like every minute and I was
just like so
yeah
um what was that like moving to La like
what problem we got we got to finish
this story all right here okay we're at
the LA part so you're in high school
you're not fighting people no you like
comedy no I played a little basketball
but it wasn't good and uh I was on the
team
and they would never let me shoot the
ball
they would just let me rebound and
um yeah then I just went to college made
some really good college friends and
then I was in college and I got a uh I
applied for an internship at Saturday
Night Live and went down to my mother
drove me from Boston to New York and
then I met I met on Dateline and I met
on Saturday Night Live and uh and I went
on Saturday Night Live I wore like a
three-piece suit
I remember my mom like bought me a suit
at Marshalls and and I walked in to
Saturday Night Live and I was like oh
like
like no one wears a three-piece suit
list I look like a total door
and uh because it's like it's it's
Saturday live it's like it was like uh
born on like Counter Culture or like you
know people were just walking around and
like you know sneakers or whatever but
then they they gave me the internship
and then I worked there then I worked
for Norm Macdonald that is so yeah that
was that was that was the best what were
you doing for Norm I was just uh like
it's just his assistant just faxing
jokes
when they would do update they'd have
like lots of people send in jokes so
just organizing the jokes and then
wanting him he would go through them
here like a cigarette in his mouth and
and um yeah so that was that was fun I
did that and then then I started
performing when I was like
like 23 start doing like stand-up and
characters and did a little UCB what
were your characters uh I used to do I
used to do a guy called the shaman that
was a Jim Morrison a guy that was in a
Jim Morrison cover band okay
um I did a lot of uh I used to do my
girlfriend who was like really emotional
um I don't know I did I did all kinds of
dumb characters
um but yeah and then
um yeah I moved to LA did stand up tried
to act made a couple movies
um and then when I was in um
I was just doing stand-up one night at
The Improv and uh David was in the
audience and then he's he talked to me
after he's like oh
you should come to YouTube and I was
like oh okay and uh and I was like oh
yeah I mean it's like just knew that
there was uh something there for sure it
sounded so fun yeah you know and I
remember I was kind of like oh I can't
go I was like 43 at the time I think and
I was like I can't do YouTube on my 43
and he was like oh why not like just go
do it and he uh yeah I really really owe
him my life he was he was like so he was
so great because he
he just he I remember he said to me he
was like oh how much money do you need
to make a month and I was like well
you'll like this you like talking about
money here we go and he goes uh I
remember I was in his car
and he we had been working together for
a couple weeks like he kept calling me
every day because he he was posting a
lot especially like three times a week
and he was like uh he just needed a lot
of content so I was like oh yeah I'll go
I'll go I was having a lot of fun he's
like how much money do you need to make
a month and I was like I need like five
thousand dollars a month which I thought
was insane and he was like you had two
kids at that point yeah two kids yeah
and and I was completely broke and he
was like I was like oh you you can make
5 000 a month and I was like what I was
like no no way and he was like yeah just
like start a channel and I was like oh
man I don't know and so then like I made
like a very very bad first YouTube video
with him and
um
and then maybe like
four months later I was making like 35
000 a month really yeah wow nope before
that though I call my ex-wife yeah and I
was like
she's like we need to uh she's like I
need money for something and I was like
and I was like I was like oh I got it I
got it no problem she's like what how
and I was like oh I'm making like 35 000
a month and there's just like a long
silence on the end of the phone and she
was like what and I was it felt so good
so yeah oh my God it was crazy crazy now
what about before that though weren't
you doing Vine or was that at the same
time how I did I did Vine for a couple
years and I did okay on Vine I was
making like I probably make like one
year I made like 250 000 300 through
what sponsors and stuff sponsors so
you'd get like you'd be surprised you
could sometimes you get like 10K for
like a six second Vine
what year was that because this is like
at the very beginning of where like all
of this was taken off I knew exactly
what it was it was
I started with YouTube the end of 2017.
okay and Vine this must have been like
probably my best year on Vine was maybe
2015 or 2016. wow and then it was and
then but then it all crashed like it's
I've had so many ups and downs like
literally I had three million on Vine
and things were going great yeah and and
off that vine success someone gave me a
movie
they're like I wrote a movie and they
they funded it and I was like okay cool
and then the movie took like a really
long time to make and to come out and
blah blah blah and then the day the
movie came out Vine was erased
so what was that like for you and Vine
just like disappeared yeah I sold six
copies of the movie and Vine was gone on
the same day so then I was like oh no I
was like I didn't know what I was gonna
do so then I started installing speakers
at speaker conventions I would like set
up things and I was like all right I'll
just
and that and that was like a month where
I was like I don't know what I'm gonna
do and then right after that I I met
David doing stand up
and um yeah but it was cool it was just
like you know that's something I always
tell people too is like
um I was at my lowest lowest lowest
lowest
and I was just like I'm gonna go do
stand up I was like that always makes me
feel better I love that and sure enough
if I hadn't gone and done stand up that
night
like I wouldn't be sitting here with you
guys you know what Drew you to David at
that point because this was didn't he
just start the channel then so it was no
he was doing really good before I
started with him he already had like
three million okay something like that
and he was getting like really good
views and I would watch them because I
knew about him it was really funny the
day that I met him
I had been watching his Vlogs that day
and I was like oh I was like because I
knew him a little bit from buying and I
was like I was like good for him I was
like he he figured something out and
it's like completely original I thought
and it's always friends and his friends
are funny and he did you know and I was
like I was like he figured it out good
for him
because he was always really funny yeah
and then that night I met him like
there's been a lot of weird like that in
my life that just weird Kismet right
place right time and so much of it is
just like
um
you gotta you gotta like keep
this just goes back to even like the
working out thing you gotta just keep
showing up trying to just keep going and
just keep trying and and hopefully like
you're prepared when some something
breaks I know I really appreciate and I
think it's really nice for you to think
that you like oh David your life or
whatever you said earlier but at the
same time so I was a pretty avid viewer
of David's videos like ever since the
beginning and I thought you had honestly
an Irreplaceable role I thought you were
uh let's say like a table can't well I
guess it can stand on three legs but it
wouldn't be very stable at all you know
that's nice I really think you were one
of the most important aspects of David
David's videos and he I really don't
think he could have done what he did
without his friends at all right
definitely definitely not without his
friends but I'll counter that and say
that he's a master of
just he'll he can pull in what he needs
for the video so if it wasn't me David
would have found something else that was
just as funny because he won't he won't
post anything until it's
amazing yeah but if he's that great then
he picked you for a reason right yeah
yeah yeah exactly because because you
were really good the thing that I loved
about the thing I really love most about
David is just that he we had the same
sense of humor that and that was really
really really really really nice to be
to just know that like whatever he said
I was gonna think was funny and whatever
I said he was gonna think was funny and
to to like mesh like that with somebody
even though he's like 20 years younger
than me was really cool like that was
that's the best creative partnership
I've had that's awesome him and uh and
and Brandon calvio is is really fun like
Brandon always has like really great
Instagram sketches that he'll like bring
to me and like will you be in this and
I'll be like yeah that's really funny
so but I think you deserve a lot of
credit that's nice for his videos yeah I
don't I don't think of it that way
that's the comic in me like I don't I
never think you never think you're funny
for long you know like you know when you
like tell a joke and like you like
people laugh yeah and it's like it's
over
you know you have that you have that you
have that second yeah where you're like
tennis ending yeah yes and then it's
like oh what's what's the next yeah
thing what's your process for coming up
with jokes like how do you do that uh
for jokes I don't know I mean like when
we do the roast and stuff yeah or
anything like when it comes to Comedy
like what's the what's the creative
process look like like how do you how do
you decide whether or not Something's
Gonna Be funny or how do you test it out
it's usually like an area
um
when you when you're like talking to
somebody and you're like oh that'd be a
funny stand-up joke or that'd be funny
for a video
um you just tell people you tell people
the idea and if if they laugh then
you're like okay there's there's
something there
um
like I'm trying to I'm trying to think
of something that we're working on us
working on
oh I was working on this idea the other
day like um like we take this yoga class
and the girl's a great teacher she's
really good and she's really like she's
very Zen like yoga's supposed to be
really Zen but she's also like pretty
pissed off at everybody so like we were
just saying like she'll come in and
she'll be like she'll be like hi guys
you guys how's everybody doing today and
like no one will answer and she'll be
like okay I'll just go [__] myself you
know like so it's just that yeah so
there's something funny there I think
the dichotomy like dichotomy of like a
yoga teacher they're supposed to be
super Zen that's like pretty pissed off
that like no one's paying attention you
know your career was a lot more
tumultuous than you made out like you
have some pretty interesting pivots
there was a time I was a kid I was
tuning in to my favorite show yeah Drake
and Josh oh Drake and Josh and you were
in Drake and Josh that's such a fun
that's such a funny thing because you
guys your age see it that way like whoa
he had a line in Jake and Josh but I saw
it as like
I was like broke and I had a friend who
was a writer on the show and he was like
oh let me see if I can get you some
money come in you can come today and
have one line and make
500 500 for one line yeah it's something
like that or maybe it's like you know
like 600. so yeah so you just go and
you're just like I had a lot of jobs
like that you just go and you like sit
there then you go in and do the one line
and you're in very like
very low status there because the stars
are there and
um yeah I didn't really I don't really
enjoy it I don't really enjoy like
sitting on a set that much I really like
like creating and doing YouTube I
thought that was the coolest thing
because I grew up with you in like in
like high school right like I grew up
watching like your Vines and everything
and I saw you on David's Vlogs and
everything and then come to realize that
was you in the famous Drake and Josh and
I'm like well I grew up with him
apparently a lot longer than I thought
no that now you're just like totally
embarrassed when you're doing it you're
like oh my God I can't believe I'm
hearing this I love it it's funny
because everyone else who sees that
thinks it's the cool yeah they think
it's cool yeah you're just like I gotta
get home
have you ever you ever been recognized
as the person from Jake and Josh and not
from uh
no no never no no no no no one's ever
been like man yes he never no it's never
happened they've mentioned Drake and
Josh only because I think they made a
big deal out about it in the Vlogs but
like I remember I think like David put
it in the Vlog or something so people
will say it like Drake and Josh like you
but yeah but yeah it was it was just a
it was just a job that day and I
remember the guy I remember they they
threw a cake and the cake crashed
and we were like done and then they said
oh no no no they they throw a cake on
somebody on a woman and Sugar's covered
in cake and apparently they didn't get
the shot so the woman had to go back
take off all her you know put off do her
makeup all over again and then redo the
cake
and I was just like uh do you get
residuals for that or was it like 500
bucks one time thing Josh do I still get
residuals
yes yeah and you know it's funny when
when things were
um when David's Vlogs were were on and
those checks were bigger
this is really weird maybe I think when
Josh came into the Vlogs there was like
a spike in interest in Drake and Josh
and I could see that so then those
residual checks that were like seven
dollars they would be like 200 200 yeah
incredible it's really weird so how much
do you think you've made in totality
from your what was it like from acting
15 no no from your 15 second clip in
Drake and Josh or however long it was I
probably made like you know three
thousand dollars a thousand so that's a
good that's a great great day yeah
that's pretty good over the years it's
nice they take care of you after
wow that's the
um after the what is that the processor
no no yeah it gets the acting build yeah
sag after
and I got another question about Norm
Macdonald because I'm a huge fan of Norm
I don't know if it's sacrilegious for
you to say this but like was he the same
all the time was he always that kind of
like aloof type like yeah he was like a
real loner he was like a real I think he
I think when he went and did like stand
up in like so many places and so many
weird places and that he he was like he
became
um very what's the word solitary you
know like he just didn't need anyone
else because he was was so funny and so
when I knew him he
he was great he was really nice to me
and he took me everywhere but he he
definitely had like an attitude like
um I don't need anyone you know and
which he was not good yeah he and he was
that good yeah so it was a very like
Lone Wolf kind of guy but he was also
really fun he would Gamble and he would
he would love to like play uh soccer in
the hallways and he'd love to play
basketball even though he wasn't like
that athletic and
um he yeah my my best Norm story is uh
we all went out one night and I was
really young I was like 21 whatever and
um I ended up going home with this girl
and then the next day I came in to Norm
because I was like really new to the
city like living in New York I didn't
really know and I turned him and I I
said oh my God I said this girl she um
she put cocaine on my [__] last night
and I said I'm gonna tell you this but
don't tell anyone and he goes yeah yeah
yeah I won't tell anyone you know what I
mean
that's so good
she put cocaine on my [__] and he was
like oh my God he's like that's insane
and then like five minutes later like
the UPS guy came in with like a bunch of
packages for him and he was like hey
Norm and he was like hey Jerry
this is Jason the intern he's like the
guy likes cocaine on his [__] that's
like mortified and then he did that for
like the next you know three months
he would just you just be sitting here
like a high pressure situation yeah
you'd be like maybe handing him jokes or
something and right before he's about to
go on and he would like turn to the page
and be like hey you know Jason likes
cocaine on his car that impression is
spot on that's real a lot of people can
do a norm it's pretty easy to do but
really go for it I couldn't do it I
couldn't do it I'm not even gonna try I
can't even do it he was he was the best
he was like he learned so much from him
and
I don't know he's just the funniest and
then as the years went on just watching
him like do all his stand-up sets and
stuff and watch his specials I still
watch it I watched his talk show uh
appearances all the time really him on
Conan yeah they're they're epic like
talk show appearances I don't think a
lot of people realize like a lot goes
into those like those are those are
comedic sets that they've crafted
they're not stand up they're not doing
um their stand up back they're they're
crafting something completely new
you know to do right there and I'm
always like really interested in that
yeah on like a nightly basis too there's
a lot of content that goes in on yeah
well Norm would be on Conan or or later
men like maybe I don't know maybe yeah
three times a year yeah something like
that but still
um yeah they're fun to watch if you go
back and watch them and I guess that was
what gave him a real Resurgence was um
because he wasn't on TV anymore but what
was really giving him this was surgeons
was these YouTube clips of him on Conan
and that would like fill the seats and
stuff that was what I heard him say at
least yeah yeah because they are great
they're spectacular and his last
Letterman said is spectacular
um so yeah I got a question about
edginess in comedy yeah yeah how does
Norm get away with saying the things
that he said like why because a lot of
people they pick and choose their
villains and I feel like Norm was just
one person everybody was like we're just
gonna let him say whatever he wants to
say he's a harmless dude he would do
this really cool thing a really smart
thing which was he would towards uh
later in his career I would watch him uh
he would kind of blame it on someone
else you know what I mean he he had this
he has this talk show on YouTube it's
like called the uh it's a podcast called
The Norm Macdonald podcast I can't
remember what it's called but it's
really good it's so good and at the end
of the show they would read jokes
and he would read these the most
offensive jokes and the guests would be
like oh my God that's so offensive he's
like oh my God who wrote this
you know like so he would but he wrote
it yeah you know so he would he found
ways to like pass it off or
um
yeah he just got around it smart yeah do
you feel like people have become softer
now for comedy like they have to be a
little bit more PC and a little bit more
like appropriate for all ages I feel
like people have gotten a little bit
more uh you know sensitized to Comedy
right now
like when you watch Eddie Murphy back in
like the 80s and 90s it's totally like
you can't say a lot of that stuff today
it's so it's so tough to say like
I I know that there's an audience for it
like when you go and you like um see
like live stand up and you see somebody
be go really out there like like Bill
Burr or like Tom Segura somebody like
that like there's they love it they love
it people love the idea of going into a
comedy club and like hearing something
that even more so yeah now because
they're like oh wow now we can like
we're in this place where we can really
say anything but I have noticed that
like
you know my younger friends like
yeah there's there's a softness that's
there
um and you know you just I just try to I
kind of like walk the balance I'm like
okay like I understand you know you want
to be that's you don't think that's
funny but some people think this is
funny
so yeah it's tough and YouTube is
different than stand up and it's
different is different than podcasting
and they're all they're all just so
different you know there's stuff you can
because you have the comments so if you
want to say something that's like really
insane on your podcast it's it could
blow up in your face
but in stand up
you know that's what they're there to do
they're there to really go out there and
uh yeah I think with stand up two right
now it's easy to take Clips without any
context whatsoever yeah 60 second clip
put it up so it's like what they said
what yeah you know I I don't I I I I
hate I hate I hate doing tick tocks like
we did a video yesterday uh it was like
another workout video and and Dave
Portnoy had talked about me on his show
uh BFFs and the first time he talked
about me was when I was heavier and he
was like the guy looks old he looks
gross and which I thought was funny I
was like oh that's cool I don't care
they're talking about me I do look gross
he said he looked like a mother or
whatever and he was he was doing this
whole bit where he was like I look way
better than this guy you know it's a
good impression which he does yeah how
do you do that man and then he goes and
then maybe like a year later I got in
shape and they pulled my pictures up
again and they were like Dave was like I
think it looks weird I think he looks I
think he said I look weird I think it
looks strange a guy that old is all
um and so like me and my friends were
dying really and Josh Richards was like
I think he looks good you know yeah you
know Josh yeah and and uh so they were
kind of talking about it
and so I was I thought it was funny but
that I was also kind of like yo that's
[__] up and that he talked about me
twice in a negative light after I did
all this work so then in the video which
we put out yesterday I
um I do this roast of him and the roast
is pretty good like you know we wrote it
and it's good roast and the people like
the video whatever but then like this
morning I had to the video we had to put
out a tick tock like of of the roast but
like I didn't really want to put that
road that Tick Tock out yeah context
yeah because someone's gonna go and just
see that and be like oh [__] Jason Nash
it's Dave Portnoy you know yeah so it's
I don't I don't love the internet in
that regard I try to stay away from
stuff like that but
um because I love Dave Fortner and I'm
not trying to and I don't like any kind
of Internet beef or anything like that
like I get some really stupid and I
think it makes people look really dumb
um and it it just you just drown each
other out you know
um but uh but yeah so yeah I don't like
I don't like that I don't like clipping
things and and taking things out of
context like you said yeah
I get that I think too I've had a few
Clips taken to me yeah where it's like
completely out of context you can make
anything appear however you want it to
appear basically with Clips but I'm sure
you could also do it in a right way too
of getting the right message across in
60 seconds where you could do the roast
and like get a few good jokes in there
but but add context in the beginning yes
yes yes yes yes yes and add context in
the beginning yeah which
we did in one of the tick tocks but in
one of them we didn't let's talk a
little bit more about this YouTube
Journey because let's do it you know you
you were making 250k on Vine yeah you
went to making nothing uh yes or I
shouldn't say nothing just enough
nothing because it was dead it was it
was gone it was dead and gone and then
after that you went to installing
speakers making just a you know a modest
living I'm sure doing that yeah and then
all of a sudden this whole David thing
happens he sees you at an improv bar
three months later you're making
35k a month something like that yeah
something like that yes four four five
months later where'd you go from there I
listened to Howard Stern
and I remember that there was a guy on
there who was his side guy his name was
Jackie Martling and I remember listening
to Howard and being like and Jackie left
the show and and Howard was always like
Jackie left he had such a good thing you
know so that always stuck with me like
so when I met David I I always thought
like oh wow I have such a good thing
here like you know like I love hanging
out with them I love being with them I
love making the videos so from there I
just was like this is like a once in a
lifetime uh lightning in a bottle
situation that won't be around forever
you know so let's just I'll do this for
the next few years
you know and um
and he was so he was so um focused on it
and stuff
and I and I really needed uh to you know
pay for my kids and stuff in my life so
I was really focused on it so I wasn't
into partying and he didn't drink either
so we were just every day just
trying to make that Vlog and and you
know the the truth of it was is that his
vlog
did so well that that's why my Vlogs did
well you know so I I didn't put so much
effort into my Vlogs I would just uh
just kind of like kind of slice a life
my lifestyle stuff and then I put a lot
of the focus on his Vlog because that
seemed to be like the that was the thing
that was trickle down feeding everything
so I looked at it as being on like a TV
show a little bit like is that TV show
is doing well then I can go to anything
I can go do stand up I can sell tickets
I can sell Merch this might sound stupid
but people on his Vlogs were they ever
paid to be on the Vlogs or was it more
so you get to appear but you'll we'll
draw on such a big audience that that'll
trickle over to everything none of the
friends were ever paid and they were
people that were paid to uh
yeah there's things you would have to
pay for like If you hired like an actor
for something you know maybe we would
pay them or they would pay them but no
they were never paid but but also David
never I know some people that take a cut
and David never David never took money
from anybody and he certainly could have
asked yeah for that you know so I always
felt like it was quite the fair trade
um
to go and film with him for you know a
couple times a week and
suddenly have like
a huge Instagram to have a big Snapchat
um I thought it was a pretty fair trade
you know yeah and then what did a day
look like in like a day of filming for
you let's say like David's like Dave
let's go let's go shoot something what
time are you up like so fun what yeah oh
so fun the most fun I've ever had in my
life like just so incredibly fun like it
would be like
I mean the most fun was when he would be
he would be like editing on he would
post Monday Wednesday and Friday and he
would post like Wednesday at five
o'clock he'd be like he would be editing
it like up to the wire and my Vlog would
like already be out and then uh my man
would he would post it
would die what's that oh I thought you
were gonna say your views would die oh
no no no my piece would go My Views go
your views go higher chairs
we're just going straight to David it's
the reverse no but he would post it
and I would be around the corner at my
computer and I would just want to watch
it yeah and I would like turn on his
wall and I would be at my computer he's
in the other room and I would like start
watching it and I'd be 30 seconds into
the Vlog and he'd be in his jacket
black baseball hat camera in his hand
and he'd be like let's go and I'd be
like oh man okay and then we'd go out
and so there's no down time no no no
Enjoy the moment so fun but doesn't he
track the performance of each video and
just see like how it's doing in relation
to uh listen on his phone and look at it
and Okay and like make me look at the
comments or whatever and uh
um yeah he would definitely track that
work ethic though is incredible I
remember he came to a party yeah that I
was at this must have been 2018
something like that yeah yeah he showed
up with his camera and I think you were
not there but there were two other
people with him he kind of looks around
and then he leaves and I was talking to
someone there and I said why did you
leave like he walked in and left within
a minute yeah as well there's probably
no content like he needs content right
now and yeah yeah he just he would go
everywhere to scout for like what's
gonna make the best story and what's
gonna be like interesting to film and if
it's not there like he's not just there
to socialize like he wants something
that he wants to put a piece together
that he's really happy with yeah I think
that was just for that's just time
reasons he just needed to to get it we
just needed to get it out like yeah
three videos a week there's just I
didn't realize it was three a week for
some reason I was thinking it was once a
week but yeah so like if you post Monday
at five o'clock and you're trying to
post Wednesday at five o'clock
and you've really so now you have Monday
night
Tuesday and then you have to edit all
day on Wednesday yeah and you're and
you're not and you're out late Tuesday
night so you're waking up
at 11. well I'm not because I'm taking
my kids to school but he's waking up at
11 and then he's uh
uh yeah he's gonna edit all day so you
really just have like Monday night and
Tuesday to try to put together something
funny and something it's so hard what
was the idea creation like you know like
anything we would just take anything
from any anywhere and it seemed that the
best ideas were the ones that were like
just based in reality you know like
sketches didn't really work we tried to
do some sketches they weren't funny and
just like
and it we really would take for anything
anything that we could think of or
um good ideas were pretty hard to come
by like towards the end there was just
like I remember what he had he had a
really really crazy idea once he he was
just staring staring on the back of his
uh house the sliding glass doors and his
back was to me he just goes Jay
I got it
we're gonna bury you in the backyard
I was just like which is like makes you
feel all kinds of ways like the first
way is like literally the first thing I
thought was damn that's good and the
second thing I thought was oh God I
gotta get buried
so then was that before or after Mr
Beast got buried alive
because I believe it was before I think
that would have been before so he came
up with the idea before Mr I think so
well the way we did it was way different
than Mr Beast in a way it's a different
idea if this was I'm buried and there's
something over my head and then if you
pull up and everybody goes holy [__]
there's somebody buried in the ground Mr
Beast is like really a testament to Mr
Beast yeah you know like
his fortitude uh so yeah so funny but
that was good that was that was a great
bin but the uh and I was fine but then
after being buried underground for a
while you the weight of the soil yeah
really gets to you so that was really so
they they I was like having them dig me
out isn't it hard to breathe it's very
hard to breathe like you do feel that
pressure of just like you can't move
yeah you're stuck
now I was okay I was okay it's just I
you just it just got Heavy after a while
and then vardon would had to start to
dig me out but he wasn't good with the
shovel so he was like hitting me he's
like I'll come get you Jason
I'll save you I that's pretty good his
voice his voice is different now yeah no
it's it's deeper the voice is lower now
wow yeah were you ever part of a really
demanding bit like something that took a
lot out of you demanding yeah demanding
like it just required a lot of you like
he was like oh we're gonna go fly over
here shoot this thing you gotta do this
Jason and you do it all and it's just
like unused oh yeah there's lots of bits
that you like would try to that that you
try that didn't work it get unused there
was there's so many
there's so many what sticks out to you
is is one of them I mean maybe like
getting shot with a paintball gun and it
doesn't make it
something like that it's like kind of
painful but I'm pretty good with pain
like uh
honestly the hardest stuff is uh
like flying somewhere
um in no no like taking an a lot like uh
it's it's eight it's it's eight o'clock
and he's like oh we're gonna go see Mr
Beast in the morning we're taking an 11
o'clock flight to North Carolina we're
driving two hours to see Mr Beast and
then we're flying home that night that's
honestly the hardest because I just like
a family I got a family and I can't sit
on a plane
and it's a lot heavier than and like
your back yeah I'm old so like your back
like hurts on a plane and I
I don't know yeah there was that's
probably the hardest a trip you went on
with your ex and you went to Hawaii
right yeah and uh yeah that's a great
bit enjoying your time in on the island
you know it's a it's a lovely place I'm
sure you're having a nice relaxing time
and then someone shows up and shoots you
with a paintball gun right yeah yeah
that was that was awesome what was going
through your head on that because you
weren't actually expecting that to
happen right I think he took me to the
airport and he was like
he took her to the airport and he's like
if I
how did it go oh I
do you remember I don't remember I think
it was something like I'm gonna come to
Hawaii and shoot you with a picture be
fine with that if I showed up in Hawaii
or or maybe she wanted to see him or
something like that or I don't remember
what it was but like if I showed up
would you be would you be fine with that
and you offhandedly said yeah yeah
because you didn't think you would
actually do it yeah yeah yeah I would
always say yes to stuff for the
possibility that it could happen it's
the same thing with the marriage thing
yeah
um
uh but yeah and then he um I remember I
was in the hotel and I got a phone call
like hey we want to send a gift basket
oh I know what it was I he said I want
to send a gift basket what room are you
in someone random called me yeah and
right then I was like hmm like no one's
sending me a gift basket
hotel in Hawaii and uh so then I was
just like
somehow I
oh he didn't know where I was he didn't
know what hotel I was at
he just knew I was he he hacked my I
know how he did it yeah he hacked my
Snapchat and found my location that was
how that was what was so great about it
I can't believe I don't remember this
but yeah he hacked my Snapchat somehow
found my location knew I was at this
hotel now he needed the room number
he needed the exact room number so then
he had someone call I have a gift basket
and I say 688.
and then as soon as I said 688 I was
like
oh no and then I heard a knock at the
door yeah the writing was on the wall
yeah great bit yeah yeah yeah it was
really awesome what's great about those
bits too is they weren't faked yeah you
know they're they're they're they're
they're not faked at all I mean there's
there's things that
um maybe if like someone said
if if we're filming and you said a line
that was like really funny
but the camera wasn't on like we like
would redo lines and stuff but none of
those pranks are like that's 100 real
like when Jonah got the movie deal when
Brandon thought there was an earthquake
when they they got me on Hollywood
Boulevard
um there was a bunch of guys dressed in
Elmo that started like chasing me that
was all real like I I was they got me so
all that stuff's real which is cool how
many times do you shoot down ideas
though or just like hey that's a I'm not
down for that is there anything that you
just like put your foot down on yeah
there's there's stuff that you just you
just like say no about you're just like
that that's not gonna be I don't want to
do that you just say no that's it you
know and then he and then I would pitch
him lots of ideas that he would say no
too
um that he just didn't think were funny
he was the ultimate um he would be the
ultimate decider in the end my favorite
video I have to say is a Tesla video
where you jumped it on that one that was
a recent one oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that was my personal favorite video oh
yeah that was funny all the copycats
afterwards and that one card do you see
that I saw that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah a lot of copycats yeah you saw
that one right yeah you got like 10 feet
in the air I was like what are you doing
yeah he ate it like the car crashed in
another car gosh I think after that they
uh they put like a police car there for
a while wow did they yeah it's a crazy
slope yeah have you ever been there no
it's just an insane you know California
is so funny that the people that haven't
been here don't understand it's
just Mountains and the the way that the
street goes up the street basically just
goes up yeah and down and um but yeah
that wasn't David driving the car yeah
yeah
um but yeah that was that was good that
was a good one
there's lots of them you can go on and
on about them they're they're it was
really the most fun fun I ever had and
then you had a podcast with him as well
you guys got the views behind views yeah
and that was going on for a long time
like yeah it was great early in the
podcast yeah yeah yeah great guests yeah
with fantastic guests yeah but was what
was interesting to me is that like I
noticed you guys created the podcast and
then all of the sudden everybody else
started creating them and I will say
this much I've never said this before
views podcast was a huge motivator and
it inspired me to uh to ideate the iced
coffee oh that's great yes it was that's
I thought we started around the same was
it no no no because I would go on the
runs in Santa Monica and I would listen
to views podcasts yep and I just thought
it was so fun that you guys were just
hanging out with your friends and just
like yeah yeah yeah talking shots yeah
it was it was awesome and so I was like
oh telling a podcast sounds kind of fun
and I feel like podcasts are great
because the audience connects with
people on a different level yeah yeah
and I felt really connected to you guys
sure the Vlogs because I felt like I was
getting an inside look to your guys's
lives and everything but sure it was a
little bit more staged and then the um
not staged but like yeah meditating sure
sure but the the podcast was so raw and
so genuine and it also validated a lot
of the the conceptions that I had from
the Vlog yeah and it really made me feel
like I know you guys I knew you guys and
from that point I was like I was like
Graham needs to connect more with his
audience I think he and I have some
pretty funny banter yeah fun to have a
podcast that's great the the the the
thing about the podcast that I like so
much was that that he was making the
Vlog at the same time so there was um as
hard as it was to do a podcast too
because there's just one more thing we
had to do but there was so much to talk
about it was so great like it was just
so easy you could be like they saw the
video that day
of whoever he was with let's say he was
with like Justin Bieber that day and
then that night he could say like he
could tell you a little bit more about
what happened when he shot it or so I I
love that I mean it was it was really
really fun to do
um I don't think we'll ever do it again
why is that I just
um I don't want to speak for him but he
just doesn't like doing it he doesn't
like doing it he's just not into it
that's totally fine he's just not into
it like I and you know it's fair I
honestly I did prefer it in the old like
like I would just do the audio anyways
well yeah we did once once you release
the video we did too um I I would just
like consume it with just the audio and
then once you guys switch to the video
yeah and then had like the super nice
set which I liked in the beginning yeah
but then I I honestly preferred it where
it was just like all you guys yeah that
was me too for me that's what most
people like it was on the couch
episodes on here I tried a couple video
episodes yeah yeah they didn't and they
they were great but they I he um he
didn't like how it looked it's just
another logistical challenge as well
whereas recording audio is just very
much simpler yeah and I respect David
for that like he just doesn't want to
he's like I don't want to do it anymore
and I was like okay cool you know he
just told me and that's it and I still
thought man it was fun part of me was
hoping it would come back I know I know
it would I would love to do it I just
think we're all like um they're all
getting older you know and they're just
I don't know they just don't have the
need to do it there's not there's not as
much to talk about I I think you make
things to talk about yeah like I'm sure
your life is still just as exciting as
it as it was during the other times in
different capacities you just have to
look for it yeah there's just less funny
stuff going on and that was probably
what was interesting about the podcast
you know it was just like there was so
many funny things that were happening
and now we're just kind of like ah let's
hang out go to the movies the end of the
podcast was it something that kind of
just phased out or was it a conversation
that was that happened where it was like
yeah we're gonna stop this yeah it was
just like as it was as it was going on
we could just kind of see like oh it
just didn't it just wasn't the same and
how do you justify it people grow people
change you know like he's a he's a young
guy he's 26 I think so you know he's
just like people change I'm sure Graham
is thinking this how do you justify
stopping something that's probably
extremely lucrative yeah and seemingly a
net benefit on all capacities right like
it helps like keep the fan base like
excited to hear more about you and your
engagement up and you're putting more
content out there it's probably making
good money how do you justify just
stopping something like that
Dave you want to take this one
uh no I don't I don't know he I like uh
hmm
well like money isn't everything right
and also if you have a commitment to
like a certain level of quality
and you can't meet that quality then
um you have to stop
um and I'm sure you guys I will do this
podcast for a set amount of time and
that's everything in life everything in
life is a set amount of time nothing
lasts forever
um and uh you know at one point you guys
will go yeah why don't we break you're
gonna do you're gonna do the podcast for
more than 10 years this one I don't know
it depends yeah
in my mind I think automatically five to
ten years uh just like right off the bat
like yeah that's yeah that's great yeah
that's great and and uh and so I think
that we we reached a point where the
quality was not where we wanted it to be
and you guys might you know I don't know
I think
I don't know I kind of lost my train of
thought I wish I wish I wish it was I
wish it was was still going I really do
but
it's not I have a deep level of respect
for for the content you guys put out
because every single thing was a banger
every video yeah yeah every clip every
podcast everything was so so good and I
think that's why he stopped because he
felt the because if the value if he
wasn't gonna put out a banger then he's
not gonna do it that's the thing and and
I would say that has been I I was very
impressionable to that yeah and I still
feel similarly I Graham and I have this
debate every once in a while where I'm
like if we don't have a good episode to
post on a Sunday I don't want to post it
I want to make sure everything we put
out there people like we are giving so
many reasons for people to watch this
content that's great it's educational
it's entertaining it is like maximum
value possible in every measurable way
like I am very much that I want
everything to be perfect and Grandma's
like we gotta keep up with the schedule
yeah if we post our like we people are
expecting us to post it very much you
need both I agree you definitely need
both I think I was the year David and
you're me I was kind of like Dave we got
a post we got to do the Pod this week we
got ads and he'd be like oh I don't
really want to but but yeah you gotta
have both and you you have to be
consistent too so you mentioned that
your finances are a bit of a wreck yeah
I want to hear about this uh well but
you know I'm just like not the best okay
with money
how so what do you mean by that I don't
know it's just like uh I just pay I just
give give away a lot of money I just
have a lot of people in my life that I
that I pay do you just give them money
or like an exchange of service employees
or like I have employees I have kids
basically okay yeah that's it yeah give
your kids a lot of money ah my son has
my Postmates
oh I learned the other day that he has
he's had my credit card
for a while and I was like oh right
right right you didn't notice the
charges you look at your statements uh I
would notice it if it was higher than I
expected yeah I don't look at we order
from the same places so I wouldn't even
oh yeah but yeah I should I should watch
that but yeah finances suck I hate money
money's like so ugh I hate it isn't why
I don't know because it's just like when
you have it you just want to like give
it to everybody and then when you don't
have it you're like man I wish I had
more money
you know what I mean so it just kind of
comes and goes and then like YouTube is
um
things are going good now but there's it
definitely like goes up and down it's
insane yeah yeah where do you think you
spend the most amount of money
my mortgage okay I guess you got a nice
place it's okay it's it looks it looks
it has a nice view but it's very small
um and I think the Market's got down I
think I think it's when did you buy it
2019 oh you wanted a good time yeah I
did yeah what interest rate I don't know
you don't know they have no idea 30-year
mortgage you don't yeah something like
that I really don't know do you have
someone that takes care of your finances
like a financial planner manager
um
uh my 14 year old daughter looks at no I
don't know uh no I I don't I don't I
yeah I have somebody I have somebody
okay in New York that does it yeah
that's good yeah but I don't like to get
on the phone with them because I don't
like to hear about it
what if it's good news what if it's like
hey you're investing I know it's not
good
right now it's not good yes right the
markets are they're down about 20 as
long as you're steadily investing you'll
be fine yeah so put more money in it's
just Cat every every month just a little
bit put a little in every month yeah oh
I haven't been doing that I just stopped
just just you wouldn't even tell them to
do that well I put a bunch of money in
yeah and then everything went down and I
was like all right I did the same I'm
[__] not doing that again do you know
what you invested in no you don't know
oh they do it it's like Morgan Stanley
or something okay yeah they do it okay
and you tell them like here's my risk
tolerance here's what like my goal is uh
no I haven't talked about that can we
call them now yeah you should yeah
I should call Alma right now you should
probably get on a call yeah yeah hey how
are these Investments doing what are you
invested in is that I don't want to know
you don't want to know because I know
I've lost so much already it'll just
bump me out ignorance maybe there's a
way that they could just like tell you
without like you can't take it with you
Graham you know what I mean you can't
take it with it you can though if you're
going to 50 states you have 50 states to
take no I mean when you die you can't
but that's not for a very long time are
you gonna be buried with your money I
mean that might be kind of cool
just cash out
how much money do you think Mr Beast has
oh gosh
um or like because
right I've heard he has very little
money in his personal bank account uh
because he doesn't spend anything like
he he spends very little anything he
spends is just for instance he doesn't
make sense he has no money in his
personal bank account right because he
doesn't spend anything correct but
everything's not for the videos like I'm
separating personal from business if
we're talking about just him so he's had
it all in the company pretty much
everything in the company uh and it
truly seems like he doesn't spend money
on anything that's not related to
YouTube if he cashed out of everything
though sold his channel sold all his
businesses I bet you he could probably
get like a billion bucks a bill probably
I think he probably could yeah a bill
that's sick yeah yeah and he doesn't do
anything outside of making the videos
right he's always a chocolate festival
yeah feastable he has a ton of stuff he
does chocolate merch he's got of course
yeah yeah
I believe well not the main Channel I've
heard the main channel is The Lost
leader that gets people in does not make
money he makes money in the gaming and
the reacts videos okay
um because he gives away a lot on the
philanthropy Channel
um I think the philanthropy channel is
net zero right is this do you guys do
like Spanish language Channel on YouTube
no you don't do that yet someone call me
about that you don't do it yeah no no I
don't do it they called me and they were
like all set to go and then they're like
okay it's gonna cost you twenty thousand
dollars I'm like oh
I thought you're gonna do it for free
you should be like and then pesos yeah
yeah and split the revenue but it yeah
I'm trying to I'm always trying to think
of ways to make money right I haven't
thought anything Mr Beast makes a decent
amount from his different language
channels that's what I was gonna say
yeah but I think you really got it like
for his content so perfect for it like
Iraq would be another one because you
could you could watch that in any
language yeah get the joke and the humor
and like the challenge yeah uh I feel
like with our content it's very U.S yeah
English speaking oriented that like
other cultures might not be able to pick
up I love I love Instagram sketches that
can play in any country yeah like Adam W
does a lot of cool sketches and is like
oh this is funny no matter where you are
right that's why people are really cool
cobby lame got so popular is because
it's yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly yeah yeah yeah it's interesting
too because Mr Beast combined like he
had all the different language channels
yeah I heard you combined them all back
into his main Channel and now you could
dub videos like one video could appear
in multiple languages dub which
depending on where it's shown so you
don't need multiple channels anymore
which seems odd to me that they would be
able to like you the YouTube algorithm
would be able to separate like this
person is in Mexico watching this Mr
Beast video it's going to be dubbed
automatically and we're going to show
them like a different thumbnail oh I
don't know how so like the video goes
out and if I'm in Mexico it's in Spanish
yeah like you know on Netflix when you
click a video you can choose which
language you wanted to play in yeah same
thing with the Mr Beast video now oh so
there's no need to have a different
Channel no oh so you don't make as much
money uh he would just it would instead
of it being on different channels it
would all go to his one channel oh got
it yeah
I don't know how the algorithm is able
to like differentiate between that
though like where someone is based what
language they're watching maybe they'd
prefer to watch an English video versus
like Portuguese or I want to know your
motivation behind starting the new
podcast what's the reason behind that
um well I really like podcasting I think
it's really fun and
um
any views was done so I was like okay
I'll start my own podcast just try it
out see if I like it you like it yeah I
like it I think it's good I mean it's um
I like I like doing views better it was
like more fun and easier but I like
doing it myself
um
it's
um getting gas is tough yeah that's the
hardest part for us as well yeah so
we're we're trying to I'm trying to make
it more like views now with just more
friends and stuff because that seems to
be what people like anyway what was your
hard part about getting guests because I
would imagine you could reach out to
anybody and say hey do you want to come
on they'd be like yeah I mean like just
scheduling and stuff like we've had like
really big guests cancel and like
um
uh and we've gotten some big ones like
we got like Phineas to come on we got
that's Danny DeVito we got chili bun we
got Dane Cook did it TJ Miller you know
it's it's uh it's fun it's great to talk
to like really interesting people like
it's really fun and then it's also fun
just to have your friends on and like
talk about what's going on so I mean I'm
trying to do I'm trying to make it more
like views now where it's like more just
my friends because that seems to be what
people really like on the channel it's
it's interesting when you have Danny
DeVito on and then like your your
episode with your buddy Todd like does
it better than the Danny DeVito episode
you know what I mean so it's like okay
it's weird how sometimes it works that
way yeah it's crazy interested in but
the the YouTube audience is probably
more interested in you guys yeah Danny
DeVito right
David said that to me too when I started
the podcast I was like I was flying to
see Nikki Glaser in St Louis to podcast
with her because she lives there and he
was like he's like I don't know if your
audience is gonna you know
like want to hear Nikki Glaser or
whatever and and and I was like no I
know but I I have to try to do something
different you know then and then we went
Nikki was great and then that episode
did pretty good but then you go and you
like interview David's assistant and
that does just as just as good if not
better it actually does way better
honestly part of me is beginning to
realize it's a very YouTube centered
audience and if you don't Focus to like
what people want in that platform you're
gonna watch it yeah yeah but then you
know you also have to do what you like
yeah and the chance to talk to Danny
DeVito is incredible yeah I know I would
do that and so that that came in uh and
it was like he needed to do it the next
day so we went down there and we did it
and it was awesome like when you talk to
people who are like that high level it's
so freaking eye-opening and it's so
inspiring like you know to talk to
Phineas and to understand like how he
wrote bad guy and to know like I don't
know I just love all that stuff I love
talking to people I love learning and
so yeah I find that stuff really
interesting what did you learn about
Danny DeVito
Danny I love Matilda by the way that was
one of my favorite movies as a kid do
you see that I learned that I saw him
until was he in it yeah he was the
father in Matilda oh what that was him
yes oh I learned I learned that this is
a guy who was an actor in New York just
kind of like kicking around got in
um
one pull over to Cuckoo's Nest which was
like a really big movie in the 70s and
then he got Taxi
and taxi was you know back then there
was no cable show that was like that was
in 40 million homes I mean that was like
Mr Beast you know uh every week and he's
just like from there was just became
this massive massive star and like a
comedy expert you know somebody that's
just like if you if you watch him on
Sunny like just so hits the Beats like
knows how to
um
no he knows how to like play like an
edgy guy you know he has like an edge
about him and he's just like a master
just just to just to talk to him and on
that level that somebody knows about
comedy like that it's like
it's like the best way to spend your day
yeah you know learn something from him I
think for me Jack Black would be that
person would be a girl I would yeah I
think I've reached out to him on
Instagram like three times yeah he's
some he's a master he's a freaking man
have you ever watched Tenacious D yes
like he's very talented
you've never seen him it's like a
religious experience it's like so good
and his voice is really good
um yeah he's incredibly talented yeah I
don't I don't see him on too many
podcasts no and I was so excited when he
made his YouTube channel yeah he makes
some really good content it's funny and
I love the Vlogs they're just like with
him and his kids yeah like I loved that
yeah
I just stopped posting yeah he made a
really funny skateboard video where he
just goes around giving people
skateboards it's on his YouTube channel
yeah and he also plays video games too
right jablinski games yeah yeah he's
just killing it I was loved he doesn't
need to come to a podcast no he's good
yeah yeah well maybe one day for the
iced coffee hour Jack I'm not gonna give
off hope yet put some music under this
Jack
come see Graham do his podcast come on
please please
he dm'd you three times a fourth time
it's going to be embarrassing
for all of us thank you Jason yeah for
the kids
I want to also talk about relationship
advice yeah because you oh yeah I I I've
got a whole new thing on relationships I
would love to hear about it I got it I
finally figured it out you did took me
49 years I figured it out what'd you
figure out
you gotta
if you're in a relationship
you you gotta just be on top of it in
every minute in every way you gotta like
provide
support
say yes to everything never say no
and
build
a fairy tale land
that's it that's it that's all it takes
yeah because when I was married before I
used to like argue with my ex-wife I'd
be like I don't want to do that
and then you're dead right there you're
done what if you don't want to do it
though
well then you don't you know don't be
with that person so you're just you're
saying like find someone with similar
values and interests you gotta find
somebody exactly like you this opposites
attracts [__]
you don't believe it it's [__]
Opposites Attract it's so stupid two
opposite people together of course
they're gonna fight I think the
advantage those you get a dynamic of
like you know one person I was like
moving forward you know you have someone
that disagrees with you oh no it's the
worst you want to disagree all the time
that's terrible they have to provide a
different perspective on things no no
you want somebody going you're right
I'm telling you that's the secret you
really think that that's the secret yeah
I just figured it out I got I met I met
my fiance in July I got engaged in
December
we're the same person
we agree on everything
she says you want to do something I say
yes
that's it there's no there's never any
oh also this is super key
don't don't this is gonna sound really
corny and kind of like some
anti this is going to sound I don't know
however it sounds I don't care
you gotta watch your language
and I don't mean like swear words you
got to watch how you say things it's
super super important even like you talk
about yourself maybe you say like uh
podcast with graham wasn't good like I
wasn't funny or stuff like that
don't say that [__] don't don't even say
it out loud just be positive just be
like she goes how's the podcast it was
great that's it like just be super
positive all the time like or even like
when you're like phrasing things to the
woman like be careful how you say things
like phrase it in the right way like uh
try to think an example like I
I don't have a great example but like I
don't I don't I don't want to go there
like don't don't say that be like oh
maybe like tomorrow
would be better that is the secret you
know what I'm thinking babe that's a
great one you know what I'm thinking
babe
and also
also like mirror them like like be like
say nice things be like babe I was
thinking about what you said
that's killer that's killer right away
anyone loves to hear that yeah either
sex
hey I was thinking about what you said
the other day about this and X Y and Z
and maybe tomorrow is a better day to go
rug shopping what do you think like that
rather than like I don't want to go
[__] rob shopping today yeah like and
and I and I'm not like saying this to be
funny I'm saying it because I actually
just learned it and I'm embarrassed that
I learned it so late in life but like
but like or like you go out to a bar
with a woman like guys don't know this
[__] they're so stupid you go out to a
bar with your woman you [__] take
care of your woman babe what do you want
to drink
do you do that do I do I do that I
really go out to bars with girls oh you
don't have a girlfriend or anything no
oh do you yeah okay do you do that
Beyonce fiance do you do that sometimes
it depends what it is
we never go to the bar anyway it's rare
it's rare okay and if we do if we do go
to the bar it's always the sit down sort
of place where the con like a server
comes like what would you like but the
point is is that you Gotta Be You Gotta
Be constantly outputting same way you're
outputting this podcast you gotta
constantly be like little things
babe I picked up peanut M M's for you
today because I know that you love
peanut and you know whatever it is like
she's allergic to peanuts oh [__] we
just I'm kidding now I just say that uh
or or just just I mean I don't know that
that's what I think is okay you have to
keep it it feels like that's to
agreeable I mean because where's the
where's the friction I feel like there's
got to be some sort of okay I disagree
with that that doesn't have to be
friction but you also just can't like
you can't just like be a yes like you
got to be real with them like if they
want to go rug shopping and you're like
the anti-rug Shopper you just gotta say
like you know what I've had bad
experiences in the past I don't want to
go rug shopping I'm sorry go with the
four or you say how about this babe
tomorrow you should go shopping no
because you got such a good eye well
then I then I feel like
well I guess for me maybe this advice
isn't great because the spice only works
for me because I love to be with her no
matter what even though even though I
may not want to go rug shopping I'm
going to be with her so and she'll make
it fun you know what I mean no like so
that that's that's how I look at things
maybe don't take this advice but I'm
telling you you can just skip through a
lot of problems if you're just agreeable
um that's what I think I don't like
friction because like friction
the problem with friction is like she
says this and you say this
and now you're like maybe kind of joking
but then someone says something else and
then someone's feelings are hurt and now
you're not joking anymore right and now
you're fighting and then you're like
what what happened like I thought we
were joking so I don't even do that I
don't even joke I don't even I don't
know I don't even make jokes I just I
just go like because I do think she's
one that wonderful I'm like oh my God I
can't believe what a princess I have
today I mean are you kidding I've never
seen somebody so gorgeous because I do
believe that yeah you know and so maybe
maybe my advice doesn't work for
everybody but but but find somebody that
you're that crazy how did you guys meet
um a dating app okay what dating app no
she's gonna kill me for saying that I
don't think she likes that what app was
it all right babe uh Jackson all of them
but I don't think that's a big deal it's
a big deal no I don't see no problem
with it no I know but I mean some people
have like a stigma I honestly I used to
be one of those guys I'm not going to
meet my girl in a dating app but like
I've since abandoned I've since
abandoned that I'm just like yeah it
doesn't matter well I mean it's pretty
it's pretty good I mean you're sitting
on your couch you met the love of your
life you know of course you have to go
on a hundred dates of horribleness what
was the intro on the app did you say the
first message
um do you remember what that first
message was yeah
um
no I don't know what I said I don't have
the app anymore this is a long time ago
this is like two years ago okay but then
we were we were uh we weren't like
together for the last two years she
moved but then she came back into town
and now we're together and cool
um I probably just said something really
terrible I'm terrible at texting that
was the other thing that I learned is
that I'm just like really bad so it's
Jack Jack what's up yeah how are you but
not only that but Jack will go like a
week or two and just stop responding and
then hit them back up like three weeks
later out of the blue like hey what are
you up to uh but it'll be that long
Silence of just like nothing happens and
then like you don't get busy you things
come up and you can't always be super
attentive to it I feel like yeah it's so
hard it's so hard to to figure out if
you're gonna waste time on this person
yeah so your your solution is just to be
agreeable to do what they want to always
be pleasing them to
treat them like a goddess yes now as
long as they're treating you well yeah
so it when I say that I'm getting a ton
in return I'm getting you know really
thoughtful stuff coming my way too so
it's just as simple as that it's like
hey babe I made you a salad and I'm just
like oh my God I think there's something
to be said about being more positive
yeah I could definitely I agree I could
be a stick in the mud sometimes if I
don't want to do something I'm just like
you see it you see it on my face you
feel it it's just like feel it if you
feel it emanates into the room yeah
everyone in the room just can tell yeah
that's what I love about her is she
won't allow any kind of um
a negativity she just won't allow it she
has this thing called the meaning report
and uh she keeps it in her phone and if
I do do something that's sort of mean
she will write me up she'll write me up
she will write me up in the meaning
report what does that mean
well like the other day we were driving
and I got I got I got like really mad
because this woman like cut me off and
like my windows were up but I said the B
word
you know I was like oh my God that's
good [__] [__] like that
she was just like she pulled out her
phone and she's like oh my gosh like I
hate to do this but I'm putting you on
the media report so she wrote it out the
time and everything and
and then I begged her to take me off the
media report and uh she would not and uh
and that goes right to my mom
it goes through she text her mom the
meeting report will go to my mom yeah
yeah so what is your mom February 22nd
222 Jason called someone the b word
sounds like that could be taken out of
context so much in case it's just called
this lady the b word the windows were
rolled up and she was acting she was
driving horribly she was being uh she
was
but do you keep a meanie report back
a text heard I told her hey I was gonna
have an annoying report because when she
annoys me she said it wasn't allowed
I don't know no it's no [__] with that
I'm I'm like I'm embellishing she only
did that once that was the other day she
made a media report and she didn't send
it to my mom but she did threaten to
send it if I if I do that again yeah I
think that's really nice I'm a huge fan
of just positive you got to be positive
I think it's a good good thing yeah I
think about Graham is yeah he can
sometimes be a little bit of a negative
person one thing I realized I had this
like aha moment we were driving
yesterday and Graham was what did you
say you're like oh this traffic is
horrendous yeah horrible or something
like that I'm like
or it was going to be impossible oh yeah
to cross Fairfax at rush hour traffic
yeah yeah it's 5 p.m it's gonna be a
nightmare to cross I made a turn that
would inevitably make us cross Fairfax
and Graham was like oh it's gonna be a
night it's gonna be impossible to cross
Fairfax of this because it was right
before the light at Melrose and getting
all the backup of cars right and I look
at ground it's like
impossible
what do you think I am if it's possible
to cross Fairfax like this this word is
just so really funny aggressive you know
what I mean like yeah and I realized
because my brother does the same thing
my mom always gets mad at him because he
says like I I went to go get a taco at
the Taco Shack I had to wait in line it
was miserable and my mom's like you were
miserable really were you actually
miserable yeah and that's the thing
Graham does he just uses like the most
aggressive words in certain that's what
I'm saying choose your words like oh
this weather is so depressing it's just
depressing yeah it's just rainy and you
may not like it you know what I mean I
like this weather though I like this
weather too you were just telling me you
hated the rain literally when you walked
in here you walked in here and the first
thing he says camera equipment the first
thing he said was like I hate this rain
no I said it was horrible oh I said it
was horrible but it was only because I'm
carrying camera equipment from the car
over the house and it was getting wet
everything's getting I don't know I was
loving it like even my drive over here I
was super scary because the visibility
was nearly like I was driving from
Ventura and that whole 101 is just
really sketchy yeah I was loving it you
know what I mean yeah you turn a
negative situation
or just don't use such aggressive words
aggressive words like this that's
exactly what I mean like that that exact
example of like choosing your words it's
like it just for yourself yeah never
mind him obviously it'd be great for him
if you don't use those words but even
for yourself yes I agree
um
like
I had a video I posted yesterday and
like it's not doing great but I was just
like
someone asked me how I was doing it
that's great
living in like a fairy tale rather than
going like it's doing fine but rather
being like yeah yeah it could have been
bitter
that yeah I would have said like it was
horrendous yeah it was a disaster yeah
Grandpa's a video it does poorly he's
like oh I feel horrible right now my day
is ruined right now I'm just like yeah
and my day is I was like I was having a
great day like you know what I mean like
come on let's let's bring the vibe up a
little bit let's have a good time I'm
prone to it too like yeah I'll be
driving in traffic with my fiance and
I'll be like God
traffic and she'll go she'll go I like
it she goes it's it's more time we get
to spend together lovely like that you
know and you're just like that's good
yeah you mean you kind of want to punch
her in the face but I'm just kidding
just kidding um pull the car over but no
but that it's really nice and that's why
all my friends love her so much because
she's just like that's good she's just
so positive and and uh yeah you know
what the funny part was
he said that once we made that turn to
pull off and like I said eventually we
were going to have to cross Fairfax we
made the turn to cross Fairfax and there
was a light
there was a light I didn't even have to
wait for the traffic like it was just
the light hit red for them really we
just cruised across and I look at him
with the smuggish little smile I'm
telling you that stuff works manifesting
stuff or trying we were going to see um
my mom flew out to to go to the 80 for
Brady Premiere which is like a Tom Brady
movie and we really really wanted her to
meet Tom Brady like that's her Idol my
mom's like 80 years old and we were in
the we were in the car on the way over
and I just said to everybody I was just
like okay I was like let's let's just
let's just put Positive Vibes out we're
gonna meet Tom Brady and everybody in
the car was like we're gonna meet Tom
Brady we're gonna meet Tom Brady we're
gonna be Tom Brady we just kept saying
it and saying and saying it and then it
happened
how'd that happen uh we wait we waited
we waited
we
have 45 minutes but it was really fun to
wait because we paid five thousand
dollars
um but yeah I mean like you know it's
really it's really important to
like I I you gotta be positive you gotta
just remember that that's all you have
you know that's awesome and in
manifesting stuff I think like I think
there is something to it like things
like I did this thing with Harry jousy
like about a year ago and all the things
we wrote down came true what'd you write
down I wrote down I want my ideal I want
to get in shape I wrote down I want to
meet the love of my life
I wrote down and those two things
happened
I wrote down
I want to meet Dave Chappelle I want to
have dinner with Dave Chappelle and you
do that no but two days later I met Jim
Carrey that's oh wow really just
randomly and I tell you randomly it was
standing on the red carpet for the Sonic
the Hedgehog 2.
and uh so yeah this car pulls up and Jim
Carrey gets out of the car and we're
like oh [__] that's Jim Carrey and then
he just like locks eyes with us
and he just walks like right over to us
and he's just like hi I'm Jim
it was just like weird
how cool is that so cool I love Jim
Carrey and uh so I don't know I just I
just believe it I just believe that it's
even if it's like not true it still puts
you in the the right
put you in the game yeah you know
puts you in the game for good things to
happen
that is because people love people
people love positive people nobody wants
to be around
like negativity and nobody needs it they
got their own [__] they're dealing with
smile and move on right yeah well uh do
we have anything else I don't think so
is there anything else you wanted to
mention no no cool no well thank you so
much
my podcast
go check out my YouTube channel what
else it'll all be linked Down Below in
the description okay cool all right
thanks for having me thanks so much I
really appreciate it until next time
guys